we've got the second Republican
presidential debate coming up Trump will
not go there so it you can't even really
call it the presidential debate in that
the guy who's leading with 53 of the
vote or more 59 of the vote according to
some polls is not participating so
anyway it's the undercard it's the
people who are hoping that Donald Trump
slips and Falls either metaphorically or
physically and uh but one one guy is not
going to be there in addition and that
is going to be ASA Hutchinson ASA we
hardly knew you Asa has not qualified
his polling is pretty low Doug burgum
the North Dakota governor is somehow
going to appear with this debate Bristol
be there the chrysosons lives to fight
another day croissants uh Rhonda Santos
obviously will be there Nikki Haley Mike
Pence the fake Tim Scott that'll be at
the Reagan Library